turning to Ukraine where the country's
leaders are talking openly about the
possibility of peace talks even as the
fighting continues security camera
footage inside Russia shows what appears
to be a Ukrainian drone strike on a
Russian Air Base where three Russian
troops were killed Moscow says the Drone
was shot down despite the war Ukraine's
Jewish Community still managed to
celebrate Hanukkah Ian Lee has more from
Kiev
the season of Peace didn't bring any
here Ukrainian artillery continues to
bombard Russian positions around bakrud
while Russia shelled Carson killing at
least 10 civilians
president zielinski said Russia is
throwing everything at them to make some
progress amidst the war the German
family celebrates Hanukkah amen they
light the candles of their Menorah to
remember a Jewish Victory thousands of
years ago
we fight for the existence of light in
every home Victoria tells me we fight to
be a free people like in the original
Hanukkah story
Victoria's husband sister and two sons
gather for the festivities as they have
for years so they were shocked at
Putin's reason for starting this war
how do you respond to Putin when he says
he's fighting Nazism
we've known what Nazism means since
World War II she says
to say that there are Nazis out here is
total Madness
in the center of Heap a giant Menorah
Towers over Independence Square
broadcasting the holiday to the country
the family felt safe in Ukraine until
Russian troops invaded the Federation of
Jewish communities of Ukraine quickly
evacuated them along with tens of
thousands of others they eventually
returned but life is different now how
has the war changed you I'm more
stressed I I can't live normal life
because of the world to blame Putin then
in Russia for doing this I want to kill
him if you give him a gun and his head I
would shut him the family stayed up late
to watch their president a Jewish
comedian turned wartime leader address a
joint meeting of Congress
tears filled our eyes when he spoke and
that how the Americans greeted him she
tells me so are you proud of him yes
very much yeah proud of a leader who's
United the nation on what they say is
their road to another victory for CBS
morning's Ian Lee and Keith Ukraine